boutin le soleil se lève en plus donc
c'est bientôt noël et du coup les repas
de famille et tout ça et de pression
caméra pour voir le soleil et ses va
être une période un peu visible et je
pense que c'est une très bonne occasion
pour dire on va tester s'entraîner cessé
de s'améliorer à faire hashtag des
bâtons mieux parce que bon les repas de
famille
'dès que beaucoup de gens me disent
c'est pas toujours facile et en
particulier au risque de rencontrer des
avis très différent c'est un peu le
point de rencontre entre des gens qui se
rencontrent pas habituellement
du coup pas mal de divergences potentiel
dans leur réflexion
donc j'ai envie de souhaiter bon courage
et de rappeler quelques conseils à
chaque débat tant mieux pour aborder des
discussions côté ceux potentiellement
difficiles avec sérénité et avec
efficacité
quand on vit ici on cherche à faire
fléchir les autres personnes et noël
le conseil numéro 1 baas et de se
rappeler que c'est noël
c'est une saison des fêtes on est là
pour avoir du moment c'est les vacances
rien n'est pas au boulot donc que c'est
bon d'avoir des discutions plaisante le
deuxième conseil c'est d'écouter vos
proches
il est de vouloir prendre la parole
prenez le temps d'écouter et d'écouter
attentivement avec bienveillance en
essayant de comprendre ce que l'autre
veut dire ce qui peut toujours facile il
faut faire cet effort est le troisième
conseil c'est que pour entrer autres
engagements et que vous écoutez
activement penser à poser des questions
elle cherchait à aider à l'autre à
clarifier son histoire ou faire rebondir
sur son histoire sur ce qu'il y aura qu
on paie et
vous pouvez aussi poser des questions à
un peu plus peut plus choisir difficile
mais je pense que c'est important de ne
pas poser que des questions difficiles
de prendre le temps régulièrement de
vraiment poser des questions qui sont
bienveillantes
conseil numéro 4 ce que j'entends a pas
vraiment parlé encore sur ce forum mais
un petit peu quand même déjà avec le
test de turing idéologique
l'idée de faire de transformer les
propos de ce que l'autre dit un homme
d'acier surface si vous n'êtes pas
d'accord
même s'il est d'accord d'essayer de
constamment de trois questions
quelles sont les meilleures façons de
présenter ce que l'autre a en tête
quels sont les arguments les plus
convaincants qui vont dans le sens de ce
qu'il dit il prenait 20 ans de faire ça
ça permettrait de gagner la confiance de
tous et ça facilitera l'étape numéro 5
le conseil euro 5 qui est de susciter
des doutes partager des choses des
réticences à l'idée que même cet homme
d'acier finalement il est il est pas si
fiable que ça typiquement ce sera une
meilleure façon de susciter du doute
chez votre interlocuteur le conseil
numéro 6 et de penser à modérer vos
discussions à déterminer quand est ce
que bon là ça va on peut oser essayer de
déterminer paraît un peu de sujets un
peu chaud mais parfois quand c'est un
peu ton autre tendu vaut mieux éviter
ces sujets chauds piranha des
discussions des trucs de base du
quotidien des patients des hobbies et
tout ça pour calmer l'atmosphère parce
que si on continue à débattre alors que
ça va mal on risque d'avoir des bas très
contre-productif et enfin le septième et
dernier conseil
bah c'est de penser à vous aimer
mutuellement à aimer vos proches
ce sera beaucoup plus agréable c'est si
les fêtes c'est le moment pour et ce
sera aussi plus facile ensuite de parler
de sujets aussi il ya déjà une confiance
mutuelle qui existent donc pensé à
prendre le temps de démêler vos proches
et aussi de dire de le dire
explicitement et de créer une atmosphère
très sympa à voir de faire preuve de
gratitude puisque comme en parle parce
que sachs dans une vidéo récente la
gratitude
ça a beaucoup d'effets secondaires très
bénéfique
cette vidéo en en profitant pour vous
souhaiter de très bonnes vacances de
très bonnes fêtes et surtout pour vous
remercier de continuer à me suivre
prendre assez c'est vraiment ils font
six nuits que 12 à voir ici